For years, we've been arguing with our
Muslim friends about Muhammad's marriage
to a girl too young for a bra. For
years, we've been trying to convince
them that Allah shouldn't have promoted
sex with prepubescent girls in the
Quran. For years, we've been telling
them that when Muhammad promised his
followers an eternity of deflowering
virgins in paradise, he was just duping
a bunch of gullible degenerates into
fighting his battles for him.
And what did we get for all our hard
work?
No gratitude whatsoever. The Dawah guys
doubled down defending sex with
children. They tripled down. They
quadrupled down.
Until they were all piled on top of this
one topic like the men of Al-Zubair were
piled on top of Muhammad.
They just wouldn't listen.
But I eventually realized that the
reason they wouldn't listen is the
language barrier.
I don't mean English versus Arabic. I
mean they didn't agree with the words we
were using.
They didn't agree with how we were using
words like rape and pedophilia and
molestation and incest and so on.
This became a serious obstacle to clear
communication and moral progress.
Fortunately, the entire time the
solution to this problem was in the
Quran. In Surah 3 verse 64, Allah
commanded Muhammad to say,
"O people of the book, come to common
terms as between us and you."
Come to common terms. Common terms.
That's what was missing from our
discussions with our Muslim friends.
All we needed to bridge the language
divide were some common terms.
And now, thanks to our friends on Team
Dawah, we finally have the common terms
we so desperately needed.
As many of you know, in a recent live
stream, I began sharing things about my
past that no one knew and that no one
would have ever heard about had I not
shared them.
I admitted publicly that when I was 18
years old, out on bond after attacking
my father with a hammer, I had sex with
two post-pubescent but underage girls.
One was 13 years old and one was 15
years old. It was shameful, immoral,
evil.
But sometimes something positive can
eventually emerge from something tragic.
For instance, the death of a loved one
might bring together two siblings who
had a falling out and haven't spoken to
each other for years.
The tragedy might make them realize that
there are more important things than
holding grudges. This could lead to
reconciliation.
So,
if we want to look on the bright side of
my open, honest confession of the sins
of my youth, I think we'll see that
whatever short-term friction my
confession may have caused, it also
provided the perfect opportunity to come
to common terms with our Muslim friends.
We've never been able to agree on the
meanings of certain words
until now.
What words would our Muslim friends use
to describe an 18-year-old man having
sex with underage girls?
Let's find out because moving forward,
these will be our common terms forever
and ever and ever and ever and ever.
Daniel Haqiqatjou, the world's leading
defender of child marriage, posted,
"David Wood recently admitted to raping
two underage girls and forcibly
sodomizing them. He hid this from his
audience for decades and only revealed
it after others threatened to go
public." That's strange. No one was
going to reveal anything because no one
knew about it.
Weird how I can hand these guys a
confession to attack me with, deliver it
to them on a silver platter, and they
still have to lie.
But let's ignore that and focus on our
common terms. I admitted to having sex
with two minors. There was nothing
forcible about it.
But since girls that young can't
meaningfully consent to sex with an
adult, sex with them, according to
Daniel Haqiqatjou, should be called
rape.
Strong language, but for the sake of
solidarity and progress, I accept
Daniel's use of the words rape and
forcible.
And Daniel has another contribution.
"Why is Turning Point USA platforming a
confessed pedophile to teach courses on
faith?"
Good question. But even better than his
question is Daniel's use of the word
pedophile.
According to Daniel Haqiqatjou, any
adult man who has sex with a girl who's
13 years old or 15 years old or younger
is a pedophile.
His word choice, not mine.
But let's see if Daniel's fellow Muslims
agree with these terms.
Here's Muhammad Hijab.
"Christian anti-Islam apologist David
Wood's admission of raping 13-year-old
Rebecca Rebecca
has been met with silence and
justification by the Christian
community."
Silence and justification? There's been
no silence and no justification.
"This man has broken the law and put
Rebecca in serious danger.
Religious concepts, including sola fide,
do not affect legal responsibility and
the rights of others." Is this guy drunk
again?
"If this was a Muslim, we all know what
would be said about it."
So, Muhammad Hijab agrees that any adult
who has sex with a girl 13 years old or
younger is guilty of rape.
Good to know.
Jake Brancatella, aka Jake the Muslim
metaphysician, writes, "New video. David
Wood admits he raped two young girls."
So, Jake agrees that 13-year-olds and
15-year-olds should be described as
young girls, not as women.
And he agrees that any adult who has sex
with a young girl is guilty of rape.
Paul Williams of Blogging Theology
declares, "Apologist David Wood
confesses he raped girls prior to his
conversion."
Paul here might have been a bit more
forgiving if this had been about boys
instead of girls, but he agrees that
13-year-old and 15-year-old females
should be called girls, not women, and
that sex with them is, by definition,
rape.
Ejaz Ahmed, you should hear the racial
slurs he uses against Hispanic people,
writes,
"David Wood admits to being a pedophile
and committing two acts of statutory
rape. Not clickbait. He actually says
it. It all makes sense now."
Ejaz is technically correct when he says
that sex with teenage girls is statutory
rape and that this is what I admitted,
but we're going to have to toss out the
word statutory because his fellow
Muslims all prefer a much simpler word
rape. So, we'll stick with rape.
Ejaz also agrees that a man who has sex
with a 13-year-old girl or a 15-year-old
girl or, obviously, an even younger girl
should and must be called a pedophile.
Next, we have the new face of Dawah and
a rising star in the marry your first
cousins movement, Junior, who says,
"David Wood, ladies and gentlemen, the
most popular Christian apologist, the
predator who fabricated the Al-Zubair
story.
We got the story from Muhammad's
companion Abdullah ibn Masud, who was
watching the entire time.
So, I'm not sure how we fabricated it
for him.
The pedophile who insults our beloved
prophet. He proudly says, 'I had sex
with two girls, 13 and 15.'"
So, Junior agrees that a man who has sex
with a 13-year-old girl or a 15-year-old
girl or, obviously, an even younger girl
should and must be labeled a pedophile
and a predator.
Finally, we have one Dawah who says,
"David Wood is a disgusting pedo.
This is the same guy who has been
attacking Islam for decades, yet he
himself is guilty of what he accuses
Islam of."
Not quite. There were no nine-year-old
girls or prepubescent girls in my
confession.
So, interesting choice of words from the
Dawah community. Some of you may be
uncomfortable with such strong language,
but who are we to question the hikma of
our Muslim friends?
We're here to come to common terms.
And thanks to some good old-fashioned
hard work, we finally have our common
terms. According to Team Dawah, any man
who has sex with a girl, yes, a girl,
not a woman, 15 years old or younger
should be called a pedophile, a pedo, a
predator, and a rapist.
Since young girls can't meaningfully
consent to sex, any sexual activity with
them, even if the girls are willing
participants, should be called rape and
interpreted as forcible.
These words are now the official binding
common terms between Muslims and
Christians.
No, my Muslim friends, you can't take
them back. Not now, not ever.
And as we move forward in our
discussions for years to come, everyone
will refer back to this video whenever
you object to the common terms that
we've permanently agreed upon.
Of course, using terms like rape and
pedophile and predator in the ways we've
agreed upon might be new for some
people, especially for Muslims.
But as any language expert can tell you,
when you're learning how to use words,
the best approach is practice, practice,
practice.
So, to get some practice using our
common terms, let's look at a few
passages about Muhammad's relationship
with Aisha.
Then, for even more practice, we'll see
what the Quran says about sex with
prepubescent girls. After that, we'll
watch some clips of our friends on Team
Dawah to see what they think about sex
with young girls.
Then we'll take a closer look at how the
Quran describes the virgins of paradise,
with special attention on how old these
virgins are, and we'll consider what
this tells us about the men who spend
eternity deflowering them.
And finally, we'll discuss what Allah
and Jibril did to impregnate Mary, the
mother of Jesus, in the Quran, and how
Allah and Jibril should be described
based on what they did to Mary.
Sound fun?
Trust me, it will be.
First up, Muhammad's marriage to Aisha,
who was either six or seven when
Muhammad married her. The sources
disagree on whether she was six or
seven,
and nine when Muhammad had sex with her.
There's no disagreement in the sources
on this.
Sahih al-Bukhari 51:58.
Narrated Urwa, "The prophet wrote the
marriage contract with Aisha while she
was 6 years old and consummated his
marriage with her while she was 9 years
old, and she remained with him for 9
years, i.e. till his death."
I wonder what she brought with her when
she was taken to Muhammad's house for
the consummation.
Maybe we'll find the answer in Sahih
Muslim 34:81.
It was narrated from Aisha that the
prophet married her when she was 7 years
old, and she was taken to him as a bride
when she was 9 years old, and she took
her dolls with her.
He died when she was 18 years old.
She took her dolls with her. That's
strange. Dolls are considered images in
Islam, and images are forbidden.
Now I'm wondering why Aisha was allowed
to play with dolls.
Sahih al-Bukhari 61:30.
Narrated Aisha, "I used to play with the
dolls in the presence of the prophet,
and my girlfriends also used to play
with me.
When Allah's messenger used to enter my
dwelling place, they used to hide
themselves, but the prophet would call
them to join and play with me."
The playing with the dolls and similar
images is forbidden, but it was allowed
for Aisha at that time as she was a
little girl not yet reached the age of
puberty. Now I get it. Playing with
dolls is forbidden in Islam, but the
rule only applies once a girl reaches
puberty.
And Aisha hadn't reached puberty.
There are dozens and dozens of passages
about the age of Aisha in Islam's most
trusted sources, but we'll read one
more. Sahih al-Bukhari 51:33.
Notice the chapter heading. Giving one's
young children, not adults, giving one's
young children in marriage is
permissible.
Why? By virtue of the statement of
Allah, "And for those who have no
monthly courses, i.e. they are still
immature." Surah 65:4
of the Quran, which will be reading
soon.
And the iddah, the iddah is the waiting
period for a woman or a girl after her
husband divorces her, she has to wait a
certain amount of time before she can
marry another man.
And the iddah for the girl before
puberty is 3 months in the above verse.
So, if a man divorces a prepubescent
girl, how long does the prepubescent
girl have to wait before the next guy
marries her?
3 months.
And to illustrate Allah's ruling about
marriage to prepubescent girls in the
Quran, Bukhari quotes Aisha saying that
Muhammad had sex with her when she was
only 9 years old.
Narrated Aisha, "The prophet wrote the
marriage contract with her when she was
6 years old, and he consummated his
marriage when she was 9 years old, and
then she remained with him for 9 years,
i.e. till his death."
So, Muhammad, the prophet of Islam, had
sex with a prepubescent 9-year-old girl.
According to the official terminology
provided by our Muslim friends, how
should we describe Muhammad and what he
did to Aisha?
Whether we like it or not, we have to
call Muhammad a pedophile, a predator,
and a rapist, and we have to say that
this pedo forcibly raped a prepubescent
little girl. Their words, not mine.
But what about the Quran verse that
Bukhari cited?
Surah 65:4 is a little confusing if you
don't know what it's about, so here's a
crash course.
Earlier in the Quran, Surah 2:228,
Allah revealed that if a Muslim man
divorces his wife, she has to go through
three monthly menstrual cycles before
she can remarry.
But the question later arose,
what about wives who don't have monthly
menstrual cycles, either because they're
too old or too young or too pregnant?
Since they don't have monthly periods,
how long do they have to wait before
they can remarry?
Allah answers this question in Surah
65:4,
which reads,
"And those of your women as have passed
the age of monthly courses, for them the
iddah, prescribed period, if you have
doubts about their periods, is 3 months.
And for those who have no courses, i.e.
they are still immature, their iddah,
prescribed period, is 3 months likewise,
except in case of death.
And for those who are pregnant, whether
they are divorced or their husbands are
dead, their iddah, prescribed period, is
until they deliver their burdens. And
whosoever fears Allah and keeps his duty
to him, he will make this matter easy
for him."
The relevant part for us, which Bukhari
quoted in defense of marriage to
prepubescent girls, is this,
"For those who have no courses, i.e.
they are still immature,
their iddah, prescribed period, is 3
months likewise."
Just so you don't think we're
misinterpreting this verse, let's look
at three classical Muslim commentaries.
Tafsir ibn Kathir.
Allah, the exalted, clarifies the
waiting period of the woman in
menopause, and that is the one whose
menstruation has stopped due to her
older age. Her iddah is 3 months instead
of the three monthly cycles for those
who menstruate, which is based upon the
ayah in Surah al-Baqarah, see 2:228.
The same for the young who have not
reached the years of menstruation. Their
iddah is 3 months like those in
menopause.
So, according to ibn Kathir, the part of
this verse we're focusing on is about
divorcing the young who have not reached
the years of menstruation.
Tafsir Jalalayn says this is referring
to those who have not yet menstruated
because of their young age. Why haven't
they menstruated? Because of their young
age.
Muhammad's cousin, ibn Abbas, gives the
historical background. He says this part
of the verse was revealed in response to
a man who asked a question.
What was the question?
Upon which another man asked, "O
messenger of Allah, what about the
waiting period of those who do not have
menstruation because they are too young?
Along with those who have it not because
of young age, their waiting period is 3
months."
So, according to the Quran, a man can
marry a prepubescent girl, have sex with
her, and divorce her.
3 months later, another man can marry
the same prepubescent girl, have sex
with her, and divorce her.
3 months after that, yet another man can
marry her, have sex with her, and
divorce her, and so on and so on.
That much is clear.
But how would we describe what the Quran
teaches in Surah 65:4
using the official terminology provided
by our Muslim friends?
Well, we have to say that the Quran
promotes the serial forcible rape of
prepubescent girls by predatory
pedophiles.
And since the Quran is supposedly the
eternal speech of Allah, we can say that
from all eternity, Allah has been
promoting the serial forcible rape of
prepubescent girls by predatory
pedophiles. Their words, not mine.
Not surprisingly, since Allah has been
promoting rape and pedophilia for all
eternity, his greatest defenders today
also promote rape and pedophilia.
Consider Ali Dawah, who has over a
million subscribers on YouTube and who
offers this advice for raising
daughters. If
my daughter
reaches the age of menstruation, 9 years
old, I would say you are
ready to
you are ready to get married.
You are ready to get married. You are
ready to get married. As disgusting and
repulsive as that is, keep in mind that
Ali Dawah's behavior is better than the
Quran requires. We've already seen that
the Quran allows marriage to
prepubescent girls. Ali Dawah, Islam's
father of the year, wants his daughter
to wait until she starts menstruating.
But what does this mean if we're using
our official common terms?
It means that if Ali Dawah's daughter
started menstruating at 9 years old, he
would be willing to hand her over to a
pedophile who would repeatedly rape her.
And since all of his Dawah buddies
defend sex with little girls and they
arrange polygamous marriages over Zoom
calls,
you have to wonder if these guys are
passing their daughters around to each
other.
You rape my 9-year-old daughter and I'll
rape yours.
Their words, not mine.
According to Ali Dawah's BFF Muhammad
Hijab, the Quran allows grown men to
have sex with 5-year-old girls.
If you look just at the Quran,
you will get the indication that you can
have sexual intercourse with a
5-year-old. To be clear, Hijab believes
that if you go outside the Quran, you
can conclude that you should try to
avoid harming girls and so you might
want to wait a bit longer to be safe.
But he's clear that there's no escaping
the fact that the Quran allows sex with
prepubescent girls.
If you just read the Quran, it is halal
it would just it would be halal to have
sexual intercourse with a 5-year-old.
Chapter 65, verse four.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala tells us who you
can divorce and who you cannot divorce.
And then he says, "Wa la ilam yahdin."
"Wa la ilam yahdin." And the ones who
had never been pubescent before.
The reason why we don't have sexual
intercourse with 5-year-olds and
6-year-olds and 7-year-olds or whatever
is not because of puberty.
It's not because of puberty because that
verse in the Quran
actually says, "Lam yahdin." They never
had puberty before. You can't go around
that. Doesn't say anywhere in the Quran
that the woman has to be pubescent. Give
me one verse in the Quran which says the
woman has to be pubescent. One verse.
According to Daniel Haqiqatjou, a man
can have sex with a 5-year-old, a
4-year-old, or possibly even an
11-month-old baby if the parents are
sick enough to give permission.
Okay, could a could a man have a
marriage to a 5-year-old consummate it
if she started precocious puberty? If
she starts showing signs of physical
maturity, then yes, that's permissible
as I stated. That's the principle.
>> If there are signs of
So, this is something that has become
biologically impossible because
precocious puberty there are no
>> it goes as early as 11 months.
And this is just standard in the Dawah
community. They defend sex with little
girls.
But these are the same guys who call sex
with a 13-year-old or a 15-year-old rape
and pedophilia.
This means that even if they don't
partake themselves, they are knowingly
defending and promoting rape and
pedophilia.
They are rape apologists and pedophilia
apologists. Their words, not mine.
But it gets worse because Allah hasn't
just been promoting rape and pedophilia
from eternity past, he also guarantees a
future eternity of rape and pedophilia.
I'm sure you've heard of the houris
Muslims will be given in paradise. These
are the virgins Muslim men will spend
eternity deflowering.
Ibn Kathir quotes Muhammad on this.
The messenger of Allah said, "In
paradise, the believer will be given
such and such strength for women."
Anas said, "I asked, 'Oh Allah's
messenger, will one be able to do
that?'"
He said, "He will be given the strength
of 100 men."
Someone else asked, "Oh Allah's
messenger, will we have sexual
intercourse with our wives in paradise?"
He said, "The man will be able to have
sexual intercourse with 100 virgins in
one day."
If you're wondering how Allah's not
going to run out of virgins, keep in
mind he's the best of planners. Here's
what he's going to do.
Every time you have sex with one of your
virgins, Allah will turn her back into a
virgin. As we read in Tafsir Jalalayn,
Quran verses in bold, explanations not
in bold.
"Verily, we have created them with an
unmediated creation, namely the
wide-eyed houris. We created them
without the process of birth and made
them virgins, immaculate. Every time
their spouses enter them, they find them
virgins. Nor is there any pain of
defloration."
That's thoughtful.
This is how a Muslim man can have sex
with 100 virgins every day. Allah keeps
restoring their virginity over and over
and over forever.
But what else do we know about these
virgins?
Turns out there's an interesting verse
of the Quran that talks about their
breasts, but the verse gets translated
in very different ways. Here's Arberry's
translation of Sura 78, verses 31 to 34.
"Surely, for the God-fearing awaits a
place of security, gardens and vineyards
and maidens with swelling breasts like
of age and a cup overflowing."
Arberry translates this as maidens with
swelling breasts.
There are Muslims who think this verse
is about large, fully developed breasts
and they'll say this means that the
women are fully grown somewhere around
33 years of age.
But other translations say something
quite different. Here's M. H. Shakir's
translation.
"Surely, for those who guard against
evil is achievement, gardens and
vineyards and those showing freshness of
youth, equals in age, and a pure cup."
Shakir doesn't even mention breasts. Why
is that?
Well, as Muslim scholars have explained,
Sura 78, verse 33 isn't about swelling
breasts. It's about a stage of
development. The verse is about girls
with budding breasts. Their breasts are
just starting to form.
This is why Shakir translates it as
those showing freshness of youth who are
all the same age.
But don't take my word for it. You can
find this in various commentaries, but
the Muslim scholars at IslamQA have put
together a nice article for us.
The article begins by pointing out that
to understand the verse, you have to
learn how the expression is used in
Arabic. Then the scholars explain,
"Based on that, we say to you that with
regard to the literal translation of the
word kawa'ib, that's the word Arberry
translated as swelling breast because he
didn't understand how it's used in
Arabic, it is the plural of the word
ka'ib, which refers to a female with
developing breasts, as it says in Majma
al-Lugha.
Ibn Faris, may Allah have mercy on him,
said, 'Ka'b comes from a sound root that
is indicative of a thing beginning to
develop and emerge. From the same root
comes the word ka'b, which refers to the
ankle, which is the bone on the two
sides of the lower leg where it meets
the foot.
And the word ka'ba, which refers to the
house of Allah, may he be exalted, it is
so called because of its prominence and
its square shape.
A woman is described as ka'ib when her
breasts begin to develop. And here are
some sources. This is the literal
meaning of the word in terms of
linguistic roots.
So, the word ka'ib refers to a girl
whose breasts are just starting to form
and it's related to the word ka'b, which
refers to the little bone that sticks
out on the side of your ankle.
Then the scholars give an example of
what they're talking about by showing
how the Arabic word for menstruating can
be used to mean literally menstruating
or to refer to a stage of development,
someone who's reached the years of
menstruation.
And they continue,
"We may say something similar about
describing a woman as ka'ib in Arabic.
It is not intended as an erotic physical
description of any part of the woman's
body as much as it is intended as a
description of the girl in terms of the
emergence of the signs of femininity in
her as an indication of her young age
and youthfulness so that men would be
attracted to her. At this age, the signs
of femininity begin to appear in the
girl.
The point of using this word is not to
describe the size of the breasts or to
note their form or shape. Rather, the
purpose is to highlight the woman's
youthfulness.
Ibn al-Jawzi, may Allah have mercy on
him, said, "The woman is a
little girl, when she is small, walida,
when she begins to walk, then a kaib
when her breasts begin to appear, then a
nahid when they increase in size, then a
maser when she reaches the age of
puberty, then hawd when she reaches the
age of a young woman." Did you catch
that?
She's a kaib when her breasts begin to
appear, and that's two stages before she
reaches the age of puberty. Here they
consider menstruation as the beginning
of puberty.
Why is this significant? Well, according
to their system, a kaib is a
prepubescent girl. Doctors today treat
budding breasts as a sign of early
puberty. Breasts begin to form during
Tanner stage two.
But, as we've seen, our Muslim friends
claim that sex with a postpubescent
13-year-old or 15-year-old is rape and
pedophilia.
If the houris of paradise are all the
same age, and they're all Tanner stage
two forever, they're at the budding
breast stage forever,
then according to Team Dawah,
every single Muslim man, including Paul
Williams, who won't even like it,
will spend eternity as a rapist and a
pedophile.
Their words.
According to the common terms they came
up with, they will be repeatedly raping
young girls forever.
And Allah will make sure that their
victims are always virgins.
This makes Allah the god of literally
infinite rape and pedophilia, and Islam
the religion of endless rape and
pedophilia.
Allah's been promoting rape and
pedophilia from eternity past, and his
followers will be rapists and pedophiles
forever. Their words.
But, we're not done.
Because we haven't talked about Jibril,
their perverted knockoff of the angel
Gabriel.
Daniel Haqiqatjou posted,
"David, that's me, was inspired by the
example of the Christian Jesus, who
incestuously raped his own mother when
she was only 12, in order to beget
himself."
This is insanely stupid for several
reasons. One, why is he saying I was
inspired by Jesus when I was an atheist?
Two, Mary wasn't 12 according to the
Bible. The Bible doesn't say how old she
was, but it calls her a woman. This is
the same Bible that refers to
12-year-old girls as little girls, not
as women.
So, doesn't sound like she was 12. The
Dawah guys try to go outside the Bible
to later apocryphal sources like the
Protoevangelium of James to try to show
that Mary was 12 years old, but they
can't even get that right. They search
for the number 12, and they find,
"Behold, Mary has reached the age of 12
years in the temple of the Lord." And
they say, "You see? She was 12."
But, they don't bother to keep reading.
If they did keep reading, what would
they find?
"And she was 16 years old when these
mysteries happened." This is when she
was pregnant, 16. And again, this is
from a later apocryphal source written
during a time when they were trying to
describe her as young.
She could have actually been in her 20s
for all we know.
Three, Daniel thinks that supernaturally
impregnating a 12-year-old girl is rape.
Why?
Because even though Mary consented to
the incarnation in the Bible, Daniel and
the rest of Team Dawah have agreed that
a 12-year-old is too young to consent.
But again, we don't believe she was 12.
Muslims believe she was 12, and they
also believe that she was supernaturally
impregnated.
So, their Mary was too young to consent.
Now, you might be wondering why Daniel
would call this rape when there was no
sex.
Here you need to stop thinking like a
Christian for a moment and learn to
think like a Muslim.
Islam teaches that something sexual did
happen when Allah impregnated Mary.
In Sura 66, verse 12 of the Quran,
Allah's giving an example of a pious
woman, and he says,
"And Mary, daughter of Imran, who
guarded her private parts, and we
breathed therein of our spirit, and she
verified the words of her Lord and his
books, and was of the devout."
Lots of translations and commentaries
try to cover up what this says. She
guarded her private parts. In Arabic, it
says she guarded her farj, her vagina.
So, private parts is a good translation.
But, some this verse saying that Allah
breathed into her vagina,
that they try to say Allah breathed into
an opening in her garment, or they say
she guarded her chastity as if Allah can
breathe into someone's chastity.
It's also very interesting that Allah
says, "We breathed therein."
Because in Sura 19, it's Allah's spirit
who appears to Mary in the form of a man
to impregnate her. Muslims believe that
the spirit, the ruh, is the angel
Jibril, Gabriel. We read, "She placed a
screen to screen herself from them. Then
we sent to her our ruh." And the
translators add that this refers to the
angel Jibril, Gabriel. "And he appeared
before her in the form of a man in all
respects."
So, Mary saw a man walking up to her.
"She said, 'Verily, I seek refuge with
the most beneficent, Allah, from you, if
you do fear Allah.'"
She seeks refuge with Allah from this
man because she thinks he might be there
to rape her.
The passage continues with the
annunciation and the virgin birth.
So, Muslims believe that it's Jibril who
shows up to impregnate Mary. As we see
in the commentary of Ibn Kathir,
"And we breathed into it, her private
part, through our ruh," meaning through
the angel Jibril. "Allah sent the angel
Jibril to Maryam, and he came to her in
the shape of a man in every respect.
Allah commanded him to blow into a gap
of her garment." He's trying to water
this down. "And that breath went into
her womb through her private part." This
is how Isa, their version of Jesus, was
conceived.
Why does Allah need Jibril to blow into
Mary's vagina?
Well, Islam teaches what's called the
two semens theory. The two semens theory
was the theory that men have semen and
women have semen, and when the two
semens mix during sex, you get a baby.
This is different from the 30 semens
theory, where the 30 semens of the man
of all zoot mixed during sex and gave
Muhammad the strength of 30 men.
But, according to Islam's two semens
theory, man's semen comes from his
backbone.
Since Allah wanted Jesus to be born of a
virgin for some reason, he created Mary
with both semens. She had the male semen
in her backbone and the female semen in
her womb.
Jibril had to blow into her vagina to
get her sexually aroused so that her
backbone would ejaculate the male semen
into her womb just like a man.
I kid you not, here's the commentary of
Qurtubi.
"Allah gave Maryam both fluids, some in
her womb and some in her spine. Jibril
breathed into her to stimulate her
desire, because as long as a woman does
not have her desire ignited, she does
not become pregnant. When that happened
by Jibril's breath, the fluid in her
spine descended into her womb, and the
two fluids mixed, and the fetus was
attached. That is why Allah then says,
'When he decides on something,' meaning
when he wants to create something."
So, Jibril shows up in the form of a
man. Mary thinks he's there to rape her,
so she seeks refuge with Allah. But,
Allah has Jibril blow into her vagina to
get her aroused so that the two semens
inside her would come together, forming
Jesus.
But, remember, Allah says, "And Mary,
daughter of Imran, who guarded her
private parts,
and we breathed therein of our spirit."
Allah says he was blowing into her
vagina, too.
Muslims like Daniel think that since
they believe this sick nonsense, we also
believe it.
And so they say, "We believe that Jesus
raped Mary."
Muslims, not what we believe, but it is
what your religion teaches.
So, how should we describe the Islamic
view using our common terms? Well, since
Muslims believe that Mary was 12 years
old, and since they've agreed that a
12-year-old is too young to consent,
and since Islam teaches that this
encounter was sexual, Allah and Jibril
blew into Mary's vagina to get her
sexually aroused,
we have no choice but to conclude that
Allah and Jibril are pedophiles who
gang-raped the 12-year-old Virgin Mary.
I don't decide which words we use. I
just use them as directed by our Muslim
friends.
Putting all of this together,
what is Islam?
We have Allah who's a gang rapist and a
pedophile and who's been promoting rape
and pedophilia from all eternity. Their
words, not mine.
Allah has an eternal rape manual for
pedophiles, the Quran. Their words, not
mine.
Allah gives this rape manual for
pedophiles to Jibril, who's also a gang
rapist and a pedophile.
Their words, not mine.
Jibril delivers this rape manual for
pedophiles to Muhammad who,
conveniently, is a rapist and a
pedophile. Their words, not mine.
And Muhammad delivers this rape manual
for pedophiles to his followers who will
spend eternity as rapists and
pedophiles. Their words, not mine.
What is this religion?
And what have I said that doesn't follow
directly from Muslim sources and from
the common terms we've agreed to use?
To all you Muslim men who are watching,
do you really believe that this is from
God?
Do you really believe that the creator
of the universe wants to turn all of you
into everlasting pedophiles?
Do you really believe that your eternity
is going to be wake up, rape rape rape
rape rape rape rape, go to sleep, wake
up the next day, rape rape rape rape
rape rape rape, go to sleep, and so on
forever?
You seriously think this is from God and
not from someone else?
Are you kidding me?
How are you not leaving Islam?
And what does it say about you as a
human being if you know this now and you
continue to believe it and support it?
To all you Muslim women who are
watching,
according to Islam, if you make it to
paradise, and that's a big if
considering what Muhammad said about
women,
if you make it to paradise,
you'll be the wives of your earthly
husbands forever.
But as we've seen, your husbands are
going to spend eternity as rapists and
pedophiles.
Are you okay with that?
Will you enjoy paradise as a faithful
wife to your husband knowing that he's
raping 100 virgins a day?
Do you really believe that this is what
the creator of the universe came up with
for you?
Do you really think that your reward for
eternity will be sitting around while
your pedophile husband rapes young
girls?
Seriously?
Is this what you want for your children?
Do you want your sons to spend eternity
as rapists and pedophiles?
Do you want your daughters to be the
faithful wives of men who spend eternity
as rapists and pedophiles?
How are you not leaving Islam?
And what does it say about you as a
human being if you know this now and you
continue to believe it and support it
and teach it to your kids?
Now for you non-Muslims,
if you ever think I'm losing control and
going off the deep end, trust me,
there's always always always a reason.
Usually, more like five to seven
reasons.
Do you guys have any clue what kind of
mad scientist level calculations and
maneuvering it takes to get these guys
to admit all of this about their fake
God, their cheap knockoff angel, their
pedophile paradise, and that
child-molesting,
raping they call a prophet?
It's hard work making them destroy their
own religion for us while we sit back
and watch like Abdullah ibn Masud
watching what the men of al-Zubair did
to Muhammad.
So,
just let the dizzle do what the dizzle
does. You focus on learning some of this
material and sharing it everywhere.
And always remember,
sometimes
it's good to have a psycho on your side.
You thought of that.
You just thought finally. You thought of
that.
You thought of that.
You just thought [music] finally. This
is a problem with religion. There's a
reason to it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?